[Música]
prendieron Fuego lo ven
incendiaron las sillas que estaban ahí
Okay Espero que esto sea prueba
suficiente lo que acaban de escuchar es
la voz de un trabajador migrante
senegalés que vive en la ciudad de esfax
en túnez su edificio fue asediado por
jóvenes tunecinos y cuatro de sus
vecinos fueron apuñalados y trasladados
al hospital este es solo uno de los
muchos casos de violencia xenófoba en la
capital económica del país algunos
vídeos muestran a jóvenes lanzando
piedras o incluso agresiones a
trabajadores de la construcción
nuestro observador es un obrero burkinés
que vive en esta ciudad desde hace años
solo escucharán su voz por razones de
seguridad
un grupo llegó a su casa los jóvenes
tunecinos estaban armados con cuchillos
y barras de hierro trataron de forzar la
puerta al principio no eran muchos
cuatro o cinco después los jóvenes
tunecinos volvieron con más personas
eran más de 30 hombres armados con
cuchillos un hombre me envió un video
incendiaron la casa
Esta señora tuvo suerte
logró pasar por este pasillo y escalar
por ahí lo ven
todos los subsaharianos huyeron solo uno
quedó en la casa pero es un hombre
discapacitado fue él quien grabó un
vídeo suplicando llorando para que la
embajada interviniera urgentemente para
salvarlo por favor llamen a nuestra
embajada Ellos nos ayudarán la embajada
de Costa de Marfil de Camerún de Guinea
los tunecinos están incendiando nuestras
casas
destrozaron robaron cosas entraron a
buscar dinero y hubo heridos se llevaron
todos sus teléfonos los jóvenes
tunecinos son los que atacan son los
violentos son los que les robaron los
teléfonos uno no puede negociar con
alguien que está armado hay que salvarse
el pellejo
en túnez A mediados de febrero comenzó
una campaña policial contra los
migrantes subsaharianos indocumentados
también se han registrado ataques
grupales contra africanos en sus hogares
en las calles o en sus lugares de
trabajo a menudo la policía tunecina es
acusada de intervenir después de
ocurridos los hechos según las propias
víctimas subsaharianas
al principio había calma en fax mientras
que en túnel las cosas no iban bien la
gente fue de la capital para refugiarse
y dos días después que llegaron le llegó
el turno de diez de mis amigos solo uno
está trabajando porque tiene papeles de
refugiado los otros están encerrados en
sus casas no pueden poner un pie en la
estación de transporte público sin
mencionar que también hay muchos a
quienes sus arrendadores los han echado
la policía hizo una redada en los
lugares de trabajo de los subsaharianos
el viernes 24 de febrero Pero la policía
no llega a tiempo cuando ellos los
llaman es muy muy raro muy pocos medios
de comunicación tunecinos mencionan
estos incidentes ocurridos en esfax tras
los actos de violencia descritos por
nuestro observador Solo dos personas
fueron detenidas ambos hombres tunecinos
uno de los cuales fue puesto en libertad
Poco después por falta de pruebas
[Música]
aquí hay baldes completamente llenos las
paredes están empapadas las paredes
están cubiertas de moho y las
autoridades de lewisham no han hecho
absolutamente nada nuestro observador
se ha convertido en un héroe para los
más necesitados en el Reino Unido desde
2021 este hombre recorre el país
visitando viviendas en salubres y
documentando las malas condiciones de
vida de sus habitantes yo mismo crecí en
una vivienda social y en condiciones muy
muy precarias en mi casa por ejemplo
había cucarachas ratones y moho en
invierno no teníamos una parte del techo
la cocina tenía casi 100 años era tan
húmeda que se caía pedazos y estaba
infestada de cochinillas no era una casa
segura y nos ignoraban nuestro
arrendador nos ignoró durante meses
incluso años y mi papá se enfermó en esa
casa le diagnosticaron cáncer de esófago
tuvo que recibir tratamiento médico en
esas condiciones y a nuestro arrendador
no le importaba Así que decidí recurrir
a las redes sociales tomé fotos y videos
del interior de mi casa y los publica en
internet Se volvieron virales Esta es la
cocina que debe usar el arrendatario
Aquí viven dos niños pequeños las
autoridades de lewisham lo saben y así
es como tienen que vivir las
publicaciones de consiguen muy a menudo
que los propietarios actúen tras años de
negligencia menos de 24 horas después de
la publicación de este video la familia
que vivía allí fue trasladada a un hotel
por el promotor inmobiliario desde
entonces han sido reubicados en una
nueva vivienda
hablé con un arrendatario de Liverpool
al que se le inundó completamente la
casa Entre 25 y 30 veces he estado en
casas que se han inundado con aguas
residuales y los arrendatarios se ven
obligados a vivir ahí he visto todo tipo
de cosas
yo vi a una mujer al hospital porque
parte del techo le cayó encima mientras
preparaba y servía la cena en su cocina
un arrendatario discapacitado por
ejemplo estuvo sin baño en su propiedad
durante casi un año porque no querían ir
a arreglarlo Este es el peor caso que he
visto en términos de humedad y modo
Lamentablemente en el Reino Unido de vez
en cuando se oyen historias de personas
que se mueren en sus casas debido a
estas malas condiciones hace poco un
niño de dos años murió por vivir en una
casa muy húmeda y llena de moho sus
padres se quejaron antes de que el
pequeño muriera de hecho se encontró
moho en sus pulmones y en su sangre
después de su muerte Hay gente que me
dice que vive en condiciones similares
no solo en el Reino Unido sino en
Irlanda del Norte en París lo que más me
impacta es la cantidad de gente que se
siente identificada no sólo en el Reino
Unido sino en otros países gente que
vive en condiciones similares o peores
y así llegamos al final de este episodio
de Los observadores si desean ponerse en
contacto con nuestro equipo todos
nuestros contactos aparecen en sus
pantallas envíenos fotos y videos y tal
vez uno de ustedes sea el próximo
observador de France 24 Hasta pronto